Unh!
(man)
Bridget Everett is just three
points away from winning
her fourth Grand Slam.
(man)
Remarkably, she has not allowed
Schumerenka a single game in
this match and yet,
I can't take my eyes off
of Schumerenka's unique
style on the court.
Ah!
(man)
I agree, Patrick.
Schumerenka has
a charisma on the court
that just pulls
you in.
Unh!
(man)
Out.
I think one reason why
Schumerenka's having such
a difficult time in this
match is the distraction
factor of
Everett's grunting.
(Patrick)
Oh, God, it's disgusting,
they should really ban it.
Whoo!
Ah!
Unh.
(man)
Out.
Heaving and sweating
like a Clydesdale,
Everett makes the shot.
Let's take a look at
the instant replay.
Unh.
(Patrick)
So amazing.
I think the most incredible part
of Schumerenka's game is how she
manages to be so thin and yet,
still have such large breasts.
(man)
Absolutely, it's just
such a turn-on
to see tennis played with
this level of integrity.
Amy's friends and family
obviously agree.
Schumerenka's sponsor
is Herpsky premium vodka.
(Patrick)
As usual, Everett's friend
and old math teacher
is there to
cheer her on.
Got her a nice seat in her VIP
box, sponsored by ground beef.
(man)
Is what she's doing
technically cheering her on?
It looks like she's just
eating snacks from home.
Schumerenka seems to be trying
to take a moment to refocus.
(Patrick)
This is one of those key moments
where she definitely needs to
take her time
and not rush.
Yeah, don't rush that.
(man)
Whoo.
(Patrick)
Bridget doesn't seem to like the
delay in the game and as usual,
she has to try to control her
infamous attitude problem.
It's unattractive and also
she's (bleep) blocking.
Unh!
Uh!
(man)
No good, it's over.
Yes! Yes!
Well, Everett wins the
East Coast International
for the fourth time
in straight sets.
Hope she's happy.
Let's go courtside for
the awards ceremony.
Bridget, you won.
Here's your cup and
a million dollars.
Thanks, Katrina.
Really fought hard
out there--
Amy, you lost.
But you were so gorgeous
throughout the entire match
that it's almost
like you won.
Does that make sense?
What's your secret?
Um.
I love this country.
Freedom.
Amy, I'm being told
the crowd has chipped in.
You will now be walking
away with $2 million!
(Amy)
America!
I love you...
thank you!
Oh, thank you,
my country!
Oh thank you America!
Ah!
I won, I won.
Amy! Amy! Amy!
America! America!
These are for you,
take them.
I don't need
them anymore.
I love you, America.
Take them.
(Patrick)
Amy Schumerenka,
a true champion.
(man)
Great for tennis.